opération de rétorsion américaines sur
l'irak 27 missiles lancés sur plusieurs
cibles à l'intérieur du pays bagdad
affirme que ses troupes poursuivent leur
retrait du kurdistan à jumet en belgique
les enquêteurs découvrent de nouveaux
ossements humains dans l'une des maisons
du pédophile marc dutroux il pourrait
s'agir des corps des deux jeunes filles
disparues en août 1995 un triste record
d'europe 20 tonnes de cannabis saisies à
rouen pendant ce que colomb
c'était la rentrée des classes
aujourd'hui pour 10 millions d'enfants
des écoles primaires et des collèges
madame monsieur bonsoir nous reviendrons
bien entendu tout à l'heure sur la
rentrée des classes en france mais
d'abord donc l'irak 27 missiles tirés la
nuit dernière par à la marine et
l'aviation américaine sur des cibles
choisies à l'intérieur du pays c'est la
réponse des états unis à l'intervention
des troupes irakiennes au kurdistan pour
l'instant l'opération décidée par le
président bill clinton est terminée de
leur côté les irakiens réaffirme qu'il
continue de se replier de la région où
ils étaient intervenus ces jours
derniers mais dans ce type de conflit
rien ne permet de dire que l' affaire
est close eric monier
une quinzaine de fois ce matin les
navires de guerre américains ont craché
leur tomawak vers l'irak
au même moment d'autres missiles étaient
lâchés sur les mêmes objectifs au sud
par des bombardiers b-52 de l'us air
force
les objectifs tous militaires selon
washington rendent domicile
installations de défense anti aérienne
mais aussi sur des zones d'habitation
rétorque bagdad qui annonce cinq morts
et 19 les raids ont certainement été
très efficace a affirmé le commandant en
chef adjoint des forces américaines mais
le pentagone ne dispose pas encore de
bilan des dégâts pour les états unis
il s'agit de faire payer à saddam
hussein c'est le terme employé
l'offensive déclenchée le week-end
dernier au kurdistan irakien a lié à
l'une des factions kurdes
l'armée irakienne a bombardé puis pris
la ville d'erbil comme étant selon
certaines sources de nombreux massacres
bill clinton a tenu informé ses alliés
avant de lancer l'opération
londres a approuvé apporté un soutien
logistique
paris n'a ni participé et soutenu les
représailles américaines pour l'instant
l'opération est terminée mais washington
n'exclut pas de nouveaux raids si aucun
retrait irakien et constatées sur le
terrain
les etats-unis ont d'ores et déjà décidé
une extension de la zone d'exclusion
aérienne jusqu'au sud de bagdad
saddam hussein a comme à son habitude
souffler toute la journée
le chaud et le froid promettant d'abord
de détruire au nom de dieu tout avion au
style violant son espace aérien
il a laissé à son vice premier ministre
tarek aziz le soin d'annoncer que le
retrait irakien du kurdistan seraient
achevées dès ce soir
la télévision irakienne a comme précédé
l'événement sans indiquer la date du
tournage de ces images elle montrait
aujourd'hui les rues d'arbil calme et
sans présence militaire aucune alors
pourquoi le président américain s'est il
décidé à intervenir seul même s'il a
prévenu ses alliés c'est la question que
l'on doit se poser ce soir les
etats-unis entendent bien montrer qu'ils
demeurent les gendarmes du monde
peut-être ont-ils décidé également de se
débarrasser du président saddam hussein
ou encore s'agit-il d'une opération
nécessité dix ans par des raisons de
politique intérieure l'amérique doit
élire vous le savez son président au
mois de novembre
new york philippe gassot
lancé par mer ou par air ce sont au
total 27 cruz missiles d'un million de
dollars pièce qui sont venues frapper
les positions de guidage de l'armée de
l'air ou de l'adc à irakienne le
président américain dénonce les
agissements de saddam hussein
de telles actions réclament des réponses
fortes
ils en ont reçu de bonne heure ce matin
j'ai demandé aux forces américaines
d'attaquer l'irak
nos missiles ont envoyé notre réponse à
saddam hussein quand vous trompez votre
propre peuple ou menacer vos voisins
vous devez en payer le prix face
côté opposition républicaine bob doll
déclarent soutenir tous les américains
actuellement en uniforme
il s'en est pris à bill clinton qui
selon lui s'est montré faible auparavant
avec l'irak
il souhaite de cette fois on en termine
avec le maître de bagdad l'armée
américaine
elle est toujours sur le pied de guerre
philippe gassot en direct avec nous de
washington d'abord philippe gassot aux
états unis c'est vrai que dans certains
milieux on parle d'une opération disons
de politique intérieure électorale oui
je crois que c'est allé un peu un peu
trop vite parce que s'ils ont elles le
candidat clinton si l'on à 21 points
d'avant sur bob doll on fait très
attention que cette avance ne
s'amenuisent
il faut la garder jusqu'au 5 novembre le
jour de l'élection présidentielle donc
les conseillers du candidat clinton lui
répète tous les jours qu'il ne faut pas
commettre la moindre erreur
et lorsqu'on met le doigt dans une
affaire comme l'affairé irakienne
on n'est jamais sûr que cela vienne va
bien se passer donc je ne crois pas que
ce soit une
j'allais dire une opération
électoraliste il faut dire également que
bill clinton bill clinton lui et face à
une opinion publique et il ne pouvait
pas répondre à cette opinion publique en
lançant une nouvelle recommandation
diplomatique là il a fallu qu'il bascule
du côté de l'armée et il a envoyé des
crews missiles c'est à dire qu'il n'a
pas pris de risques pour l'armée
américaine les crews missiles je vous le
rappelle ont un rayon d'action de plus
de 2500 kilomètres donc il a envoyé les
engins très sophistiquée sur des cibles
bien repérer et on a pu s'apercevoir
avec le bilan même s'il ya des victimes
à déplorer du côté des irakiens ce n'est
pas le massacre concours
redoutait bien alors dernière chose
philippe est ce que l'on considère la
faire comme close ce soir à washington
je peux vous dire que au pentagone on a
toujours un doigt sur la gâchette
si le président saddam hussein n'a pas
compris car il s'agissait d'un message
n'a pas compris le message des
américains il pourrait très facilement
en recevoir un autre et si l'on croit
l'opposition républicaine qui est
beaucoup plus va-t-en-guerre que le
président clinton peut être car cette
opposition parce que cette opposition
n'est pas au pouvoir
et bien si l'on suivait ces républicains
on considérerait que cette salve de cruz
missile pourrait être le début de la fin
pour saddam hussein merci à philippe
gassot alors parmi les alliés des etats
unis
nous disions tout à l'heure les londres
approuve totalement l'action américaine
bones également en revanche l'espagne et
de manière encore plus nette la france
observe une attitude beaucoup plus
réservé c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire philippe harrouard au quai d'orsay
vous avez raison daniel disons tout de
suite que la france ne condamne fois
l'opération américains disons qu'elle
prend tout simplement ses distances
c'est vrai que jacques chirac a été
informé par bill clinton c'est vrai que
la france et les états unis et la grande
bretagne notamment n'ont pas participé à
cette opération alors qu'ils ont des
avions dans la région on sait évidemment
à paris que saddam hussein joue avec le
feu constamment les ondes est-il que
dans ce cas précis
bill clinton a réagi beaucoup plus pour
des considérations électorales que
diplomatique cela dit à paris on est
inquiet pour deux raisons la première
c'est que cela complique le jeu dans la
région une région déjà volatile d'autant
que le monde arabe dans l'ensemble est
hostile à l'opération américaine
et deuxièmement cela risque de pénaliser
la population civile irakienne
si l'opération voulue par les nations
unies vente d'une partie du pétrole
irakien contre échange de nourriture n'a
pas lieu
peut-être que quelque part cela arrange
saddam hussein mais sûrement pas les
occidentaux
merci messieurs pour ses explications
diplomatiques alors après l'intervention
américaine on peut se demander également
pourquoi le président irakien saddam
hussein a décidé cette intervention au
kurdistan
alors qu'il devait connaître les risques
encourus et que son pays est dans une
situation vous l'a dit économique
dramatique toujours frappée par le
boycott international dont la levée est
sans aucun doute
repoussé à beaucoup plus tard alors
qu'il devait être en partie levé très
prochainement explications dorothée
olliéric femmes enfants depuis la guerre
du golfe et où survivent grâce au troc
et aux tickets de rationnement sur les
marchés de bagdad un kilo de poisson
équivaut à un tiers du salaire moyen
irakien six ans d'embargo c'est aussi
une mortalité infantile a crû de 6 100 %
et un état de malnutrition généraliser
la population est noire tri ceux qui
sont allés là bas témoigne on considère
que l'embargo pourrait faire globalement
un million de 1 million d'emplois c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas humainement
acceptable pour s'en sortir bagdad était
suspendue à un accord avec l'onu la
résolution pétrole contre nourriture qui
devaient être mises en oeuvre dans
quelques jours alors pourquoi dans ces
conditions saddam hussein at il lancé
son offensive sur le codis tel accueil
c'est cet homme ici à gauche jalal
talabani leader kurde de luppé 4 qui a
fait appel à saddam hussein pour
éliminer une autre faction kurde
pro-iranienne les deux factions se
disputent en effet le contrôle du
kurdistan irakien où passe la route des
prochaines exportations pétrolières de
saddam hussein car c'est précisément
dans cette région du kurdistan que
transitent l'oléoduc irakien pour
acheminer son pétrole vers la turquie
autre hypothèse saddam hussein ne
souhaiteraient pas voir l'embargo levé
car cela pourrait l'obliger à
libéraliser son régime
et puis ou proche des versions l'a
partiellement l'embargo
les gens vont demander où est l'argent
pour la nourriture eau et l'argent pour
les mémoires encore ils voudront que la
situation s'améliore au moins 15 dans
des zones à risque de rendre le régime
responsable à de leurs souffrances
avec cette opération saddam hussein
montre à nouveau les états unis du doigt
il les désigne comme seuls responsables
des misères du peuple irakien à noter
encore qu'en israël aujourd'hui comme au
plus fort moment de la guerre du golfe
en 91
des centaines de personnes ont fait la
queue pour se procurer des masques à gaz
en prévision d'une éventuelle attaque de
missiles irak
cela dit il faut se méfier d'une
médiatisation excessive des événements
en irak qui reste pour l'instant il faut
bien le dire limiter à une opération
ponctuelle de l'armée a mis en belgique
les enquêteurs ont annoncé aujourd'hui
avoir retrouvé de nouveaux ossements
humains dans une maison que possède le
pédophile marc dutroux à jumet près de
charleroi cette macabre découverte
intervient après plusieurs semaines de
recherche cela dit pour l'instant les
deux corps identifiés lors de ses
recherches seraient les cordes and
marshall et deuil et fait le break mais
pour l'instant on en est pas encore sûr
ce soir
reportage bertrand cocq dominique mais
une fois de plus l' affaire dutroux a
apporté la mort dans ce corbillard blanc
les restes des deux corps découverts ce
matin à jumet près de charleroi dans
l'une des maisons du pédophile de corps
d'adulte pour l'instant non identifié
les ossements ont été trouvés sous deux
mètres et demi de terre avec l'aide de
chiens policiers prêté par l'allemagne
les choeurs reposer sous la dalle de
béton d'un hangar démontées dans la
soirée d'hier est précisément à
l'endroit que marc dutroux avait indiqué
aux enquêteurs la semaine dernière peu
après 10h ce matin le médecin légiste de
charleroi arrivés sur les lieux ils
assistaient à l'exhumation et procédé
aux premières constatations
le juge aussi étaient sur place et puis
peu avant midi le porte parole de la
gendarmerie confirmé la macabre
découverte
les ossements vraisemblablement de
nature humaine dans l'organe si ces
restes humains ont depuis été identifiés
en tout cas la justice a décidé de n'en
rien faire savoir avant demain et la
belgique retient son souffle
on pense évidemment à anne et fieux ces
deux jeunes filles dont dutroux a
reconnu l'enlèvement à ostende
l'année dernière la sphère n'est pas
fini le juge qui l'instruit jean michel
conrad a quitté jus mais cet après-midi
en voiture blindée est sous la
protection de deux hommes de l'es6
l'équivalent belge du gign les
précautions récente qui alimente les
spéculations sur les difficultés qu'il y
aurait à enquêter sur les crimes de la
banda du trou
à noter encore que la justice et la
police belge ont rendu visite aux
parents d'anne marshall les deniers fait
lambrecq donc cet après midi les deux
jeunes filles enlevées en 9 95 par marc
dutroux pour les avertir des découvertes
ferrer aujourd'hui dans la maison
dubet sans leur confirmer officiellement
si ce lycée bien de leurs enfants cela
dit ce soir la télévision belge affirme
que des sources proches de la justice
affirme donc que les deux corps sont
bien ceux de tram marshall est relié
fait l'ange en france c'est à chambéry
le président de la chambre d'accusation
de la cour d'appel qui a été placé en
garde à vue pour être entendu dans le
cadre d'une affaire de moeurs
il est soupçonné de s'en être pris à des
jeunes filles mineures membre d'une
association de loisirs dont il est
lui-même l'un des responsables la
rentrée des classes maintenant
aujourd'hui en france pour 10 millions
environ des colliers des maternelles
écoles primaires et collèges la rentrée
n'est pas simplement vous le savez la
sphère des enfants c'est aussi celle des
par marie pierre farkas philippe jan
cees matin là il fait toujours froid et
où les grands se sent tout petit on s'en
va vite pour ne pas pleurer
on veut tout savoir de la nouvelle
maîtresse et un peu lâche on appelle
même les papas au secours
je suis encore plus triste que l'ue
attend et on adore ça fait plus ou moins
bien mais bon on sait confiante dix ans
une très bonne faculté d'adaptation et
oui là
voyez il m'a quitté je suis tout seul en
fin de compte il à retrouver les copains
et copines et je crois qu'il est après
deux mois passés avec quatre enfants à
l'arrêt devant dieu les vacances
commencent pour les parents une rentrée
c'est pénible
on a beau se dire que la tristesse des
petits et éphémère on sait qu'il reste
trois longues heures actuelles inutile
invivable attendre bêtement la
délivrance de la pause déjeuner ce matin
j'ai rien fait du tout étonné que des
bus est attendu en vain
on est ambitieux ce matin mais là on
repart amand s'est très bien passé
charlotte est content
alors pour mettre fin au stress du
premier jour les directeurs d'école ont
décidé de se couper des parents les
parents je crois qu'il ne s'y font
jamais pour eux c'est toujours l'anxiété
fait parce qu'il met un peu la pression
sur leurs enfants ils veulent tellement
qu'il y ait une réussite et on les
comprend d'ailleurs
dans ce collège de soucis en vue on les
a invités à partager le pot les repas à
la cantine du 6e ils ont adoré le pool
comme sauter les couverts en inox et
l'eau du robinet dans de verre
incassable
ça change du primaire complètement c'est
un peu effrayant non plus pour les
parents pour les enfants mais
bon je pense que superbe allée tout le
monde va se faire ce soir 10 millions de
parents se sentent comme soulagé et
après tant d'émotions partagées
c'est sûr ils vont bien dormir
dans les zones dites sensibles comme
montfermeil en seine-saint-denis
certains collèges se sont dotés de deux
professeurs principaux lieux d'un pour
mieux assister les enfants dans leur
début de scolarité en 6e reportage
olivier caroff marie pierre cassignard
c'est parti pour un grand saut dans
l'inconnu
l'école primaire n'est plus qu'un
souvenir le collège un lieu étrange
plein de couloirs de salles et de
professeurs principaux pas dire qu'on
est plus important que les autres c'est
à dire simplement que normalement
qu'ancien problème c'est nous qui sommes
chargés de régler les preuves
aujourd'hui aucun problème tout ce
qu'attendent les professeurs c'est que
l'univers du collège deviennent
familiers au fur et à mesure on
s'habitue et beaucoup de libre aussi la
sixième est devenu à elle seule deux
cycles d'adaptation à l'enseignement
secondaire une année capitale dans ce
collège de montfermeil la séance zones
sensibles car c'est là qu'on va devoir
prendre des bonnes habitudes vous
recouvrez vos livres et du plastique
si vous voyez que ce mauvais état
pensées allaient recoller c'est à vous
de le faire
la rentrée on s'en faisait tout un monde
après une bonne heure et demie en classe
première récréation et premières
impressions
il y avait certains profs qu'ils étaient
très méchant alors
j'avais peur je voulais savoir comment
ils étaient si c'était sympa aux fins
c'est pour ce à quoi j'avais peur une
rentrée sans histoire à montfermeil
même si dans certains cas on attend
surtout de retrouver maman parmi les
nouveautés du primaire maintenant les
écoles charpak du nom du prix nobel de
physique français qui parraine un nouvel
enseignement des sciences dans 83 écoles
pilotes
reportage dans l'une d'entre elles à
vaulx en velin dans la banlieue
lyonnaise didier guillon les écoles
primaires jean vilar à vaulx en velin ce
matin pour les élèves de cette classe la
rentrée était synonyme de nouveauté de
découverte
l'établissement est en effet un site
pilote pour une opération baptisée
opération main à la pâte
objectif aller plus loin que les cours
théoriques et faire découvrir à travers
des manipulations et des expériences la
chimie l'optique la biologie ou encore
la construction mécanique
c'est en démontant en décortiquant en
construisant que les élèves après en
aurait elle au lieu de recevoir quelque
chose on leur dit c'est comme ça qu'ils
voient là là ils doivent trouver
eux-mêmes et de le tester il regarde ça
mange vraiment ils vérifient et du coup
s'approprie donc je donne plus de sens
c'est bien parce que des expériences
hall est en effet directement pour
confirmer en chimie gel mais dans un
petit projet tout mélanger après ça y
est relaté sont devenues partout
l'enseignement au tableau noir n'est pas
fini pour autant l'expérience ici est
vécue comme un complément pratiques
indispensables aux élèves de découvrir
un périscope d'ausculter un réveil de
comprendre une photocopieuse à eux
d'appréhender les rouages de la vie
l'enfant est confronté à une situation
mais ce qui devient important c'est ce
qui pourra en retirer pour plus tard il
n'est pas question de faire des enfants
qui seront des eaux scientifique dans
quelques années il est question d'avoir
des enfants qui réfléchissent cette
année 83 écoles participent à
l'opération main à la pâte
initié par le prix nobel georges charpak
mais d'ores et déjà d'autres
établissements aimerait en faire autant
enfin si le ministre de l'éducation
nationale est plutôt satisfait de cette
rentrée ce n'est pas le cas des
syndicats cette année c'était pas arrivé
depuis longtemps
cinq fédérations syndicales de
l'enseignement ont d'ores et déjà appelé
à une grève le 30 septembre prochain
pour protester principalement contre le
projet de budget 2009 197 de l'éducation
nationale chantal kimmerlin sur wiiware
ils ont réussi à se rencontrer après
quelques années de différence six
fédérations d'éducation et leurs
syndicats affiliés ont voté la grève
unitaire contre les restrictions
annoncées pour le budget 97 et la
suppression de 5000 postes d'enseignants
contre le licenciement de plusieurs
milliers de mètres auxiliaires employé
depuis des années nous avons vraiment
l'impression que l'éducation nationale
est à un tournant que le gouvernement a
choisi une orientation qui remet en
cause la priorité au service public
d'éducation
sa qualité et l'aide aux familles les
plus défavorisées
je pense qu'il faut absolument que nous
soyons bien compris des parents d'élèves
et de l'opinion publique
j'espère que c'est tout le pays qui va
se révolter comme ça c'est dur pour cela
nous avons choisi cette date du 30
septembre qui à la veille de l'ouverture
du débat parlementaire
nous espérons enfin que le pays va se
ressaisir à ce niveau
y compris pour les lycées qui ne feront
leur rentrée que la semaine prochaine la
france devrait donc connaître le dernier
jour de septembre un mouvement de grève
importante de la maternelle au terminal
triste record d'europe pour la france
avec une saisie de 20 tonnes de cannabis
sur le port d'oran en provenance de
colombie
michèle fines bernard ap si la police
n'avaient pas interpellé les trafiquants
cette herbe de cannabis auraient
rapporté à la revente pas moins de 20
milliards de centimes
c'est l'une des plus grosses prises
effectuées sur le marché européen
officiellement il s'agissait d'une
cargaison de jean elle cachait en fait
20 tonnes d'herbe de cannabis provenance
le cartel de cali en colombie
traditionnellement il était déjà dans
l'herbe
la cocaïne mais il faut pas oublier que
au départ ce sont des gens qui ont
trafiqué avec trois grammes de cannabis
la drogue étaient arrivés par la mer
dans un container le cargo qui l'a
transporté venait d'anvers mais les
policiers étaient renseignés
lorsque le bateau est arrivé dans le
port du havre ils ont discrètement mis
en place les surveillances c'est une
sphère de livraison surveillée
on a prévenu les autorités que
là où ça passait ou ça cassait il
fallait pas être intercepté ce container
du havre le chargement a été transporté
par la route jusqu'à un entrepôt à froid
les policiers surveillaient toujours le
30 août dernier un camion est venu de
belgique pour récupérer la marchandise
c'est là qu'ils ont décidé d'intervenir
quatre trafiquants de drogue le livreur
un colombien les acheteurs belge et
français ont été arrêtées quand ou 20
tonnes d'herbe de cannabis
elles seront brûlées mais par petites
quantités le travail de l'office de
répression du trafic des stupéfiants
convient de voir en action est un
travail de fourmi fait de recoupement de
collaboration internationale et de
filature à ce propos voici un document
réalisé par un cinéaste qui a suivi
pendant des mois et des mois
ces policiers dans leurs différentes
interventions thierry curtet l'autoroute
entre la belgique et rotterdam
et depuis cinq ans un terrain de chasse
pour les vendeurs de drogue pour
approcher les clients toujours la même
méthode à bord de leur voiture
les dealers se porte à la hauteur des
automobilistes français houben sq ce
soir là ce sont des policiers belges
français hollandais qui joue les
touristes contact là
le contact est toujours très rapide
comme attendrissante voiture de la
police néerlandaise
les pratiquants et leurs clients se sont
arrêtés pour discuter le prix les
changes de drogue doit se faire dans un
autre lieu
et dès que la proposition est faite la
police néerlandaise se lance
l'interpellation est rapide
ces rabatteurs pour la plupart du temps
de jeunes marocains il parle français
ils n'ont ni drogue ni armes sur eux les
peines encourues sont donc faibles mais
cela permet ensuite de remonter les
réseaux ça après les grandes proportions
ya déjà cinq ans mais bon depuis les
années 70 que c'est que ça existe en
blanc n'est jamais allée proportions
aussi grand que la maison maintenant
ce soir là la collaboration des trois
polices européennes a permis
l'arrestation de plus de 50 personnes
mais parfois le résultat n'est pas
l'acte dans les salons d'un grand hôtel
parisien
un premier contact en juin un kilo
d'héroïne que d'autres jeux qui quand
dans la mallette 450 mille francs à
peine un coût d'achat seront infiltrées
un réseau les contacts dureront
plusieurs semaines avant de se rendre
compte que le dealer n'en fait pas la
marchandise
je veux
autre affaire cet homme qui arrive de
province à un lourd casier judiciaire
les policiers pensent que dès sa sortie
de prison la réactiver un réseau de
trafic de drogue
la filature comment elle va durer deux
mois
planques écoutes téléphoniques les
policiers antidrogue perdre sa trace
plusieurs fois et finalement ils
arrêteront à son retour d'amsterdam
charger un assortiment de six kilos de
drogue faute a ajouté que le travail des
policiers chargés de la répression du
trafic de drogue est parfois remise en
cause pour des raisons de procédure
c'est le cas aujourd'hui à toulouse
trois italiens arrêtés en 94 en france
en possession de plus d'une tonne de
cocaïne ont été relâchés la justice
condamnant la méthode des policiers qui
avaient infiltré le réseau
en bref encore dans la sphère des sans
papiers le ministère de l'intérieur a
finalement régulariser 73 nouveaux
dossiers soit 24 de plus que prévu ce
chiffre porte à 122 le nombre de
dossiers réglés sur 227 à l'étude
une bombe a été découverte hier soir
dans la basilique de saint laurent sur
sèvre en vendée où le pape jean paul ii
doit se rendre le 19 septembre prochain
l'engin de fabrication artisanale a été
désamorcée
c'est le curé de la basilique qui a
découvert la bombe hier soir donc
comment réduire le déficit de la france
à 3% pour respecter les impératifs du
traité de maastricht à les séances de
le gouvernement français vient peut-être
de trouver une solution miraculeuse il
fallait y penser
c'est l'argent des retraités de france
télécom qui va servir à régler
l'addition explications l'orbit quand la
france signent le traité de maastricht
en février 92
elle est loin de se douter de ce fait
incroyable
c'est grâce au téléphone et à lui seul
que cinq ans plus tard le pays sera in
extremis au rendez vous d'une étape
cruciale de la construction européenne
explication le traité de maastricht
exige que les pays de l'union et réduit
leur déficit public en 97 à 3% de leur
richesse nationale
or en france à cause d'une croissance
très faible
on est mal parti pour descendre sous les
2 145 milliards de déficit
oui mais miracle l'état vient de trouver
37 milliards et demi dans les caisses de
france télécom de l'argent mis de côté
par l'entreprise pour payer les
retraites de ses agents du téléphone
jusqu'à l'an 2000 et même au delà
l'état se fait donc prestidigitateur
d'une main ils remplissaient caisse d'un
seul coup avec tout cet argent
de l'autre il versera lui même chaque
année ces fameuses retraites
il s'y est engagé il faudra déjà trouvé
7 milliards pour l'an prochain et à
terme ce n'est pas une très bonne
affaire mais ce tour de passe-passe
permettra à la france de remplir les
exigences européennes pour 97 sur le fil
nous tournons maintenant belgique à
jumet où se trouvent d'autres auraient
spécial bertrand cocq on a
officiellement identifié les corps
découverts cet après midi bertrand
oui en tout cas on a maintenant une
confirmation officielle de l'identité
des deux jeunes filles année et fieux
c'est bien ce qu'on craignait ce sont
donc elles dont on a retrouvé les corps
cet après midi la confirmation vient du
plus haut niveau elle a été faite il ya
un instant par le premier ministre belge
qui a parlé d'un lâche assassinat
mais depuis quelques jours déjà les
parents d'anne et des fieux avait perdu
tout espoir de retrouver leur fille
vivante
merci à bertrand pour ces précisions je
vous rappelle donc que ces deux jeunes
filles avaient disparu en août 1995 et
que marc dutroux le pédophile arrêté
avait reconnu avoir procédé à leur
enlèvement
bref encore devrait encore pardon en
matière de politique intérieure
française l'ancien premier ministre
monsieur raymond barre apporte son
soutien à la politique d'alain juppé il
estime qu'elle est conforme aux réalités
du moment c'est ce qu'il a déclaré à
l'issue d'un déjeuner avec le premier
ministre aujourd'hui
et puis encore bernard tapie qui a donc
officiellement démissionné aujourd'hui
mardi de son mandat de député des
bouches du rhône comme il l'avait
annoncé la semaine dernière
les temps passés les mods aussi carnaby
street à londres est avant dans la rue
la plus célèbre des années 60 pour sa
mode excentrique ne fait plus recette et
le groupe hollandais propriétaires des
immeubles veut s'en débarrasser
nostalgie donc avec etienne leenhardt
c'était l'âge d'or l'époque où les
beatles et les rolling stones se
fournissaient chez john steve carr
novice suisse vivait un rêve en noir et
blanc et en couleurs lemon et c'est ici
sur 3 ha de rues pavées ou les voitures
avaient encore accès et des dizaines de
boutiques engranger les millions
trente ans après qu'arnaud me suis tu as
pris des rides et ne fait plus guère
illusion les magasins d'alors ont laissé
la place et les rares qui sont restés
entretiennent la nostalgie il ya plein
de gens qui gagnent ici et qu'ils
pensent trouver de vieux groupe de pop
music
mais évidemment ces groupes ont tous
viennent ils ont atteint la cinquantaine
on ne vient plus ici qu'en touriste des
millions de personnes passent chaque
année dans carnaby street à vide du met
ces terres des sixties que vantent les
guides de vacances et que la plupart
d'entre eux n'ont pas connu ils en sont
pour leurs frais que des touristes y a
aucune ambiance je trouve qu'un complet
changement quand même 9 la même chose je
ne sais pas même vous attendiez à
trouver autre chose
ultime signe des temps l'ensemble est à
vendre voici l'un des heureux
propriétaires les édifices sont à lui le
langage est donc de circonstance je
pense que commercialement c'est une
meilleure affaire qui lie à 30 ans dans
les années 60 il y avait des voitures
partout aujourd'hui c'est une rue
piétonnière
on peut se promener librement sans avoir
peur de se faire écraser
avis aux amateurs les 93 immeuble de
carnaby street sont mises à prix 560
millions de francs l'atmosphère est
gratuite mais à la chance
en france la firme de chaussures bailly
a été placée en redressement judiciaire
jusqu'à marche mars prochain pour
l'instant les activités vont donc
continuer pour ce qui concerne la
société myrys un autre chausseur un
industriel de limoux a présenté un plan
de reprise qui devrait préserver environ
700 emplois sur les 11100 actuelle les
galeries lafayette ont 100 ans
ce magasin du centre de paris est sans
doute le plus connu dans le monde et
depuis 100 ans
il s'est toujours passé quelque chose
dans ce magasin geneviève moll pascal p
1896 le petit magasin créé par théophile
bader 76 mètres carrés rue lafayette les
femmes pouvaient déjà eu partie liée
pendant un siècle elle ne s'en priveront
pas dans ce magasin qui grandit très
vite et devient le temple de la mode et
de l'air du temps vous êtes d'origine et
et elles viennent du monde entier
la plupart du temps accompagnés je suis
ici avec ma femme je pense qu'ici on
peut trouver les choses qui vous même
vous ne pouvez explique t parce que
c'est le plus extraordinaire c'est pete
la province
et à chaque quand je viens à paris se
passe d'abord galeries lafayette
il faut bien que depuis un siècle le
magasin à la fabuleuse verrière de 1912
à hull autour de se faire connaître la
politique de communication comme on dit
aujourd'hui a commencé en 1919 avec
l'avion d'un fou volant
jules védrines qui s'est posé sur le
toit des galeries puis les expositions
de mode se sont succédé jusqu'à celle
qui doit s'ouvrir dans quelques jours
avec des mannequins portant les sous
vêtements et les vêtements du fli a
traversé de magasins c'est l'histoire du
siècle faut payer ou pour payer tra
c'est un résumé des temps modernes
et si cette genèse on devenait une cité
engloutie et bien je pense que dans 1
habillé d'année on retrouve exactement
notre civilisation au travers de ce
grand bain du jeu
on dirait une lors que les femmes
avaient bien de la chance de pouvoir
aider les états unis viennent en sport
il n'y a plus de français au tournoi
l'open de tennis de new york puisque guy
forget vient d'être éliminé en huitièmes
de finale par l'espagnol goretta battu
en trois sets festival du cinéma
américain à deauville présentation du
film droit de tuer l'histoire d'un père
de famille noire qui se venge de deux
hommes qui ont violé sa fille avec
sandra bullock
kevin spacey qui s'était fait connaître
auparavant dans un film qui avait eu un
grand succès oui je suspecte
nicole cornu langlois jean louis malle à
un jeune avocat défend un père meurtrier
des violeurs de sa fille face à eux un
autre avocat impitoyable les avocats
sont très semblables aux acteurs vous
savez chacun réussi une forme de
performances pour convaincre un public
où un jury que son prêt de vue est le
bon une juriste redoutable se joue à la
défense c'est l'énergique sandra bullock
beaucoup appris avec ce film je pense
comprendre la passion de ce jeune avocat
le désir qu'il a de changer le monde et
la frustration d'avoir affronté toujours
les mêmes préjugés et sow voit le
réalisateur joel schumacher s'est
inspiré d'un livre de john grisham sur
un fait réel dans le mississippi je ne
crois pas que l'on ait le droit de tuer
quelqu'un d'autre mais il est très
difficile de condamner un parent qui
venge le meurtre de son enfant
c'est difficile de le pointer du doigt
et dire ce que vous faites est mal vu
comment résister à la tentation de
rendre sa propre justice le droit de
tuer c'est l'un des thèmes de réflexion
de ce film sur la violence le racisme
nos valeurs traditionnelles
autant de sujets d'actualité qui ne
peuvent laisser indifférent ici ou
ailleurs
voilà pour l'actualité avant de nous
quitter retour sur la rentrée des
classes aujourd'hui pour près de 10
millions d'enfants quelques images venez
ici et là et qui rappelle que chaque
année les enfants changent et restent
les mêmes
voilà dans quelques instants la météo
sophie davant orage violent sur le sud
est et du soleil ailleurs températures
de saison sur l'ensemble du pays 20h50
la folie des grandeurs le film de gérard
oury avec cali sapritch louis de funès
et yves montand
rires assurés 23h55 le dernier journal
philippe lefait demain à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités gérard leclerc recevra
l'écrivain michel koutouzis sur les
problèmes de drogue 13 heures patrick
chêne quant à moi je vous retrouverai
avec beaucoup de plaisir
demain soir à 20 heures je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
bonsoir